pour moi c'est le meilleur c'est gilles
verdez aussi déguiser pour halloween
alors aussi beaucoup posé la question
est ce qu on se déguisait ce qu'on
déguise pas et peu après on sait
chauffer et quand vous allez voir les
déguisements
c'est à dire moi en fait j'ai le
déguisement le plus pourri je vais
demander à valérie bénaïm cas le
deuxième costume le plus pourri de venir
valérie bénaïm c'est la deuxième plus
pourris ou à la frankenstein des
conquois frankenstein et pourquoi pas
oui mais c'est parce qu'une fois que
vous tenez à travers cette pac où elle
fait très très peur
c'est bien ton quoi beetlejuice se voit
pas d'un calme toi mais toi là-bas merci
calme-toi mes toiles à bari merci vous
êtes en quoi ça sera pas non je suis un
petit chaperon rouge pour mais chapeau
rouge qui fait rothko vous avez parrot
dont beaucoup mi-temps kouaoua celle ci
où le fils d'yvette horner
le clown ça coûte d'accord mais il s'est
fait parce que tes cheveux épais comme
ça devrait aller isabelle morini bosc
qui a mal mais de la moitié du mouloud
fait ni l'abaisser et libérer le pire
c'est que ces poudres est naturel non
mais non mais c'est une paire belge te
jure au délire
ah ouais ah ouais bah ouais bah merci
vous êtes en quoi en green way c'est
vrai alors allah dans la danse toujours
un gars mettant quoi compléter devront
au compte goutte avait traîné
fethi de fois me dégoûte
ah oui ah oui mais lotus la taupe est
pour moi c'est le meilleur c'est gilles
verdez salami ah ouais vous allez faire
des histoires de tous les deux
j'ai toi t'as pas besoin de faire un
lieu où fin on sait que non mais
franchement c'est moi je crie la pop et
maléfique l'om vous imaginez vous allez
ça chez vous sans rigoler jradi mal à la
fois moi oui je suis la reine de
magnifiques
dites-nous chibout qui vous fait le plus
peur dans l'équipe
voilà moi pour moi pour moi c'est
raymond
[Musique]